[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily the
murder of a georgia beauty queen tara
grinstead there were several
reference samples from
individuals that did not match the
evidence that were tested well dna found
on an item at the crime scene be allowed
in the coming murder trial and new
details revealed in day five of johnny
depp versus amber hurd what was your
understanding of why mr depp was late
occasionally on the set of pirates five
my understanding was he was having
arguments with amber but first johnny
depp himself takes the stand today is my
actually my the first
opportunity that i've been able to
speak about this
case we're live with the fairfax county
courthouse to break down the captivating
testimony law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmark the star
witness takes the stand in a trial
that's captivating the world johnny depp
himself testifies on tuesday in the
multi-million dollar defamation suit
against amber hurd
long crime network's jesse weber was
inside the courtroom when depp took the
stand he joins us now live in fairfax
virginia to break down his testimony so
far
yeah hey brian even if you didn't know
that johnny depp was about to take the
stand you would know something was going
on and i'll tell you why first of all
there was such an increased court
presence outside the courtroom and also
one of the strange things that never
happened so far before in this trial is
they locked the doors going into that
courtroom they actually had to use a key
card and the last measure of security
that they took they removed everybody's
water bottles from the courtroom in case
they might throw something at johnny
depp now when it was announced that he
would take the stand they announced his
name there was some murmurs in the
courtroom and then brian i kid you not
complete silence when he was speaking
you could hear a pin drop the jurors
were watching him like hawks amber heard
was focused on him not showing much
emotion this is his time this is his
time the first take to tell his side of
the story about what happened he went
everything from his abusive relate his
abusive childhood to how his stardom to
how his life changed after pirates of
the caribbean and how he met and courted
amber heard but of course the main
question is why why did he file this
lawsuit why air his dirty laundry in
front of the whole world well that is a
question that he answered when he began
his testimony take a look i had to wait
for my opportunity to
address the charges
which were
criminal charges
and and and then they just weren't um
true so i i felt
the responsibility of
clearing the record
as um
the only
the only way that i could get that i
could
get to the point where i could speak
um has
really
taken
this full six years
and it's been six years of
trying times
it's very
strange when
one day you're
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds you're
quasimodo
and um i
i
i didn't uh
deserve that nor did my
children nor did the people who have
believed in me for
all these years i i didn't want anybody
any of those people to
believe that i had
done them wrong or lied to them or that
i was a fraud
i i
i pride myself on honesty i pride
myself on
truth truth is the only thing i'm
interested in
other
lies will get you nowhere but
lies build upon lies and build upon lies
it's too much to cover i i
i'm obsessed with the truth
what do you think of depp's why at the
end of the day do you think he should
have brought this case
well look i think for him in order to
sell this story and remember the story
is that amber heard publicly lied about
him and then he's also claiming that he
was the victim that is a story that only
he can sell that is and you know look
he's an actor but at the same time he's
a great storyteller and so this is his
case that he's bringing and he feels
after this week and i have to mention
the testimony that we've heard so far
from key witnesses who said they've
never observed him abusing amber heard
and never observed any injuries on her
part this is now the cherry on top
obviously there are going to be more
witnesses after him but he needs to come
forward and tell this and so far he is
trying every which way to convince this
jury that he is telling the truth and
she is not jesse it's interesting you
bring it up that way because i'm
listening to deb speak and he sounds
very purposeful when he speaks but i've
seen comments run the gambit of theories
what do you think of the way in which
johnny depp is speaking
he's careful he's very soft-spoken he's
careful he's deliberate in his word
choice he he's taking a long time
sometimes to explain certain points but
i'm telling you the jury is sitting very
close to him and they are resident
they're not taking their eyes off of him
they're not looking to the side they're
listening to every word that he has to
say and you know what i think that's
honest i think he's coming off quite
credible because he says i'm not one of
my characters who can do a million words
a minute this is who i am and i'm here
to tell you who johnny depp is now jesse
while many are spellbound by depp on the
stand you're looking at this as a lawyer
and a journalist you mentioned to me
there may have been two times that he
slipped up on the stand what were they
okay so number one
that whole first speech that he gave he
never mentioned that washington post
article from 2018 once that is the
purpose of his defamation lawsuit he
talked about statements that were made
but he never tied it back to the
defamation to the washington post
article i think that's a big problem and
number two he focused so much on saying
that he never physically abused amber
heard but he didn't quite address the
psychological mental or verbal abuse and
in fact when he was talking about his
mother being abusive to him he said you
know the verbal and psychological abuse
was sometimes worse than the actual
physical abuse i know that's something
that amber heard's lawyers are going to
jump on him later on all right jesse you
promised that you surprised me you
didn't tell me about this before i am
surprised this is interesting i think
it's going to come up on
cross-examination uh later on in this
case but of course we'll see if those
points get hit on thank you
still ahead on law and crime daily a
cold case will soon have its day in
court we look ahead to the coming trial
of ryan duke but first our coverage
continues of the johnny depp versus
amber heard defamation trial when we
come back more from depp on the stand
[Music]
welcome back we're sticking with the
johnny depp and amber her defamation
case out of virginia as depp took the
stand on tuesday johnny depp told jurors
how an abusive childhood affected his
relationship with heard
in the beginning of my relationship with
miss herod
there was
from what i
recall and what i remember she was
she was um
it was as if she were it was she was too
good to be true
she was
attentive she was
loving um
she was smart she was
kind she was funny she
was understanding she
um
and we we had many things in common
certain blues music and
well music
literature things of that nature so
for that year
or year and a half it was uh
it was amazing within a
year or year and a half
she
had become this
it's another person almost
we're joined today by criminal defense
attorney bernard villalona co-host terry
austin and once again jesse weber live
from fairfax virginia but with no
alpacas this time jesse talk to us about
the story depp gave about his mother and
father did it seem to mirror his
relationship with her
it was so important he was basically
telling the jury without actually
telling them i am my father amber heard
is my mother i am the abused man the
abused man who doesn't end up then
fighting back and actually resorting to
physical violence but deciding to leave
confrontations whether to leave the
marriage to leave the room and that's
what he wants to leave the jury with
that he is a kind shy introverted person
who would never do the things that amber
heard is accusing him of doing and that
he is just the victim of abuse himself
psychological abuse verbal abuse and
physical abuse so it was an important
moment for him to start off his
testimony by ultimately putting that
that image in the minds of the jury yes
interesting jesse as you said i'm
watching the video we have there of
depth and his shoulders are like this
and it seems just like that as you
described bernard how do we gauge the
credibility of a man who made even me
believe he escaped an island on a raft
made of turtles dev's still talking
about his past but how does it how's he
doing so far
so i think johnny depp is doing an
excellent job on the stand he is
remaining patient he is taking his time
and answering the questions he has all
of us hanging by every word we're
waiting for the next word to come out
that's how he asks us and we're not even
inside the courtroom so just imagine the
people in the courtroom just imagine
those seven jurors that ultimately have
to make that decision in this game so
johnny steph has already gave us a lot
of background of who he is what his
upbringing was like to put everything
into perspective and i think that it's
weighing well with the jury but still we
have to see how he hangs doing
cross-examination because that's the
most telling yeah terry i'm kind of
thinking this more legally now as you go
on the standard for dep is pretty high
because he's a public figure so do you
think depp's legal team is trying to win
in this court the court of public
opinion or both
oh i definitely think they're trying to
win in this court and the court of
public opinion obviously they're trying
to tell a story as jesse mentioned
they're telling the story about his very
difficult childhood how his mother
abused his father and how he wanted a
different life he became addicted to
opioids but he's not a monster and that
all along we know that heard has
exaggerated the truth and so i do think
they're trying to prove the defamation
obviously you have to show that the
statements were false that they were
public and that they were stated and
that there was malice because he's a
public figure and i think he has
mentioned some of that she knew they
weren't true we'll probably see some
more of that as we go along yeah i'm
expecting depth to be on the stand for
at least two maybe three days i think
we're going to see a lot of him end this
case as we continue jesse thank you as
always for the great reporting there in
virginia hope to see you soon coming up
on law and crime daily a beloved georgia
beauty queen and teacher murdered years
later the accused killer is set to stand
trial plus those closest to johnny depp
take the stand what they say happened
between depp and her
[Music]
welcome back we're continuing our
coverage in the multi-million dollar
johnny depp and amber heard defamation
lawsuit before depp took this stand on
tuesday jurors heard from sean bett and
a member of depp's security team bet
laid out the abuse he witnessed in the
relationship
she was crying this was at the point
when
the the arguing was taking place quite
frequently
and i was telling her i go you know i
said amber you know this can't continue
you guys are either going to kill each
other you're going to be in jail and you
know with tears and everything she says
but i love him and i'm not going to lose
him and i says but you guys can't keep
doing this i overheard her saying to him
he's a fat
you johnny and you too sean
at one time when
you know she went to throw a water
bottle or plastic cup down the stairs
and it bounced kind of in johnny's
direction but i ended up
getting him and we you know got out of
there as soon as possible at any point
during during miss herds and mr depp's
relationship did you ever see any
injuries on misheard no
how about on mr depp
yes i saw another injury around
would have been march of 2015.
he had
a swollen kind of cheekbone eyelid
jurors also heard from keenan wyatt a
friend of depps who also works as a
sound engineer on many of his movies
wyatt told jurors about an incident
involving herd on a flight from boston
to los angeles
what if any conversation did you have
with
am miss heard on the flight well at one
point i went up to her and said
something to the effect of you know he
cares about you and all of a sudden she
snapped and started yelling at me how
dare you talk to me
get away from me
yeah so
i went back to a seat and minded my own
business
when she said those things to you um
would you describe the tone of her voice
if you remember it she she was abruptly
loud it was a quiet plane all of a
sudden it got very loud you get on the
airplane and it's your testimony
that
ms heard
had a a bad tone of voice with mr depp
is that correct
she had a bad tone of voice with me
okay
in fact wasn't mr depp saying pretty
horrible things to misheard i don't
recall that
bernard in order for depth to win he has
to prove herd's claims are flat out
false so far the testimony has been
about herd abusing him but if she gets
up on the sand and says that he hit her
even just once
what does that do
for depp's claim and his reputation
exactly brian and that's going to be the
issue in this case the good thing is
well i'm not the good thing but since
both of them are counties suing each
other they're also pointing the finger
at each other so they're both saying
that some one of them is lying so if one
of them is lying then the claims can't
stand true because of course the the
defense to any defamation case is true
the problem is is that this jury's not
going to be able to determine whose
credibility should i believe should i
believe johnny depp should i believe
amber heard i just don't know so where
does that leave the jury and that's
going to be the huge task that this
jury's going to be tasked with because
if just one juror believes that oh
one of these incidents actually took
place amber heard was actually hit at
least one time then there is truth to
her article all right now terry at one
point law and crime had over a hundred
thousand people watching the trial most
of them calling for justice for johnny
as we hear about heard's abuse to him
could this case shed light on men being
victims of domestic violence maybe a a
him too movement
well i'm not sure about a him too
movement obviously the number of abuse
cases by men against women still far
outnumber the reverse of that but what
this case is demonstrating to everyone
is that abuse has no gender it doesn't
matter if you're male or female they are
seeing that abuse can be done in here we
are seeing that amber has abused depth
emotionally and mentally and even
physically yeah i will agree the numbers
are there i'm not sure if that does or
doesn't create a movement but from what
i understand the reporting of men as to
domestic violence is heavily
underreported so i'd be curious to see
if this brings this issue to light when
we come back the murder of georgia
beauty queen and teacher tara grinstein
what both sides discussed at a recent
hearing for ryan duke and what you could
expect at his coming trial
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back nearly 20 years after the
death of a georgia beauty queen and
beloved teacher her accused murderer
will soon stand trial investigators
believe ryan duke and bo dukes are
responsible for grinstead's murder the
pair are not related prosecutors say the
two were former students of grinstead
years before she went missing after her
disappearance in 2005 the case just went
cold
duke and dukes were both taken into
custody in 2017 when a tip led to their
arrest in 2019 beau dukes was tried and
found guilty in connection to
grinstead's death ryan duke is expected
to stand trial next month ahead of the
trial duke appeared in court this week
where both sides discussed a latex glove
found on grinstead's property after she
went missing prosecutes argue the glove
has duke's dna on it while defense
attorneys say the georgia bureau of
investigation did not follow protocol
when collecting the dna
i have not withheld
any
documentations that any documents
or documentation associated with
generation of reports in this case and
the non-conformity that you've discussed
in looking at those it did not affect
any of the original testing back in 2017
that identified ryan duke as the
majority contributor to the dna on the
globe correct
correct
a judge made no ruling on whether the
dna on the glove will be allowed in the
trial is expected to be a contentious
debate at the coming court proceedings
jury selection in ryan duke's case is
expected to begin on may 2nd make sure
to stay with the law and crime network
for gabital gavel coverage of the highly
anticipated trial
grenada as we listen to arguments about
this glove and the top and taking the
facts as we know them so far how
important is this glove to the case is
it o.j simpson glove important or glove
in the middle of jamaica important
it's really important and crucial to the
case for the for the prosecution you got
to think the only two things that are
really connecting ryan duke to this
murder is his statement which he says
was a lie and also this glove that ties
him to the scene so if they can get
themselves away from this glove this
will be a huge dent in the prosecution's
case because normally what jurors like
to believe it is things that can't
change and that's having to deal with
dna dealing with the science
absolutely now terry if the collection
of the dna didn't follow protocol
isn't that for the jury to decide if
that evidence is believable or not or
should the judge decide if this if this
dna comes in at all
you know what in my mind brian there's
no question that this is the type of
evidence that the judge should
absolutely admit when he's trying to
determine whether or not to admit
evidence he has to look at whether it's
more probative or prejudicial this is
not prejudicial this is the type of
evidence that a jury needs to determine
and look at whether or not it is
credible and what they're going to do is
listen to those witnesses and if the
witnesses said that the gbi the georgia
bureau of investigations if they did not
follow protocol then in fact the jury
can say listen that evidence is not as
important or it is not something that i
am going to take into consideration when
i'm trying to decide this case so it's
definitely something that the jury
should see i think that they can look at
all of that they can make their own
determination and we'll probably get
experts as well yeah i can see the
defense making some very good arguments
on that i know we've made them in the
past thank you both and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you